(peaceful instrumental music)
- [Voiceover] The town of Regent is dying.
I said, if someone doesn't do something,
this community will be a dead community.
I have a paved road from
interstate to Regent.
Now what do I do to bring
people down 30 miles?
(peaceful instrumental music)
Then it dawned on me, nobody
is gonna drive 30 miles
for normal sculptures,
but they might drive
for the world's largest.
I started the Enchanted Highway in 1989.
I've been at it for 28 years
and it takes me roughly about
four to five years to do one sculpture.
The first year, local ranchers
taught me how to weld.
I put in eight hours a day
to get one sculpture done.
I used old oil well tanks, I cut 'em open,
and I flatten it out and
that's 90% of my metal.
It's a passion project right now.
I started with the world's
largest tin family.
The man is 45 feet tall,
the woman is 43 feet,
and the boy is 23 feet.
Geese in Flight has over 300
length of oil well pipe on,
over 15 miles of weld on it,
and is in the Guinness Book of Records,
the world's largest scrap metal sculpture.
It's something I will continue
on till I'm six feet under.
Then I hope it continues on after that.
I want people to see that this guy
who didn't know how to weld,
didn't have an art class,
if he can create something like this,
I can do almost anything.